what if there is no other life
what if this is just
the end
[Music]
hey guys pete here this is my breakdown
for episode 8 of foundation season 1. it
was a good follow-up to one of the
better episodes and i think it's a good
sign heading towards the end we hit all
the different stories except for brother
dawn and from where i'm sitting there
were some pretty good reveals one big
cliffhanger on the invictus so we'll
start the recap there but first a quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
episode 8 the missing piece then this
video won't be for you and with that out
of the way let's get into it before we
catch up with what's happening on the
invictus there's a flashback to nacreon
where we see a young pharah experiencing
the planetary attack salvo was able to
pull these details whenever she was
reading pharah earlier in the season and
here farrah says that after they were
gone talking about the empire ships
there were no children left only
warriors and i guess it does a good job
to set up why farrah's the way she is
how all consuming her desire for revenge
is even when salvor makes some great
points about how terrible her plan to
jump the invictus into the center of the
planet trantor is it would kill everyone
on the capital planet but her people and
everyone else in the outer reach would
be on the hook for that and while the
empire wouldn't let something like that
go the threat for salver is that if she
doesn't help them then all those hunters
that were left behind will kill everyone
on terminus starting with her mother
there's still a ticking clock situation
until the next jump most of the
scientists they brought with them are
dead when they finally disable the
defenses salvor opens the door and she
finds a gun on the ground she fires it
at pharah and is able to get inside
alone with louis there they put together
what was happening with the crew they
find out that the captain killed herself
there and when they find the navigation
cradle we get a little bit of background
and history into how jump ships evolved
this is from a time before they had
spacers so everyone on board had to
sedate themselves before a jump and we
get an explanation that folding space
was as much intuition as it was science
and the bottom line here is that what
needs to happen is someone needs to
connect their brain to the navigation ai
to guide the ship somewhere safe or
it'll continue making random jumps
problem is this is a death sentence
since there isn't time to do the
necessary surgery and because salvor
sees herself as an outlier she
volunteers and says that she wants to
guide the ship to terminus as that's all
playing out we see that hugo did find
his way to a communications relay he's
not dead he rerouted himself to one of
the mine sites he turns it on and he
sends out an sos to the thespins on the
planet salvor's mother says they need to
evacuate terminus city because the nall
field around the vault is continuing to
expand and she thinks it's going to
overtake them all which is a tough thing
to sell to the enacrions in charge
because they'd have to take the fence
down when we get back inside the ship
there's just five minutes left farah and
rowan are still outside trying to break
in and salvor is trying to talk lewis
into hooking her up to the navigation
here we see her thinking change because
of her visions she had thought that she
was there for a reason and now she
thinks this is it she's meant to
sacrifice her life to get this ship to
terminus but before lewis can hook her
up to the navigation he gets shot by
pharah a fight breaks out between her
and salvor and then we see the thesman
show up but they turn out to be too late
and the ship begins to jump and
disappears so that's our cliffhanger is
where will it end up based on what we
learned in this scene they may find
themselves somewhere pretty far away
from the action going on on terminus
with brother day we see that he's
committed himself to a pretty serious
risk by agreeing to do the spiral he has
to give up his protective aura and have
his imperial nanobots removed and he has
to take this trek with no food no water
and no rest where for the first time in
his life he's going to be subject to
injury less than half of the people who
start this trip make it to the center if
they do the goal is to make it to a cave
in the center called the mother's womb
that has a pool of water inside there's
special salt around it and after you
submerge yourself in the pool if the
mother is willing you'll see a vision
each one of these is unique and deeply
personal and a group of zephyrs will
interpret what it means it's an
interesting situation it's not just
physically difficult if he doesn't make
it that would give halima a huge
advantage in her arguments against the
dynasty and we see the trip is a
struggle after he gets pretty far into
it he meets another man they have a
conversation where we learn a little bit
about regular people in the empire
people who live outside of trantor and
at one point when brother day drops to
one knee after injuring his foot this
person tells him not to give up and
helps him up later the tables are turned
the man drops and when day reaches out
to help him he says that the mother is
calling and submits by dropping to his
second knee when day tries to at least
help him off the path where he'll be
able to get help he refuses as he wants
to die right there rather than being
saved he explains that a peaceful
transition to a holier life is the
mother's greatest gift and because the
emperor doesn't have any faith in this
religion he tries to get him to change
his mind he says what if there is no
other life what if this is just the end
the man just lays on the ground and says
maybe we'll meet again you can tell me
what you saw and cleon has to continue
the struggle on his own he finally makes
it to the cave and he finds the pool we
see him laugh with joy as he gets into
the water and it looks like he is
experiencing wonder as we watch him
splash the water over his sunburned body
and drinking it all in that cuts to him
in front of the three zephyrs where he
explains what he saw he said the salt
started to move and it began to swirl
lifting off the floor of the cave it
formed a stem in three petals and as
he's talking we see that halima looks
worried the three zephyrs the
representations of the mother maiden and
crone talk to each other and then ask if
he's familiar with the mythology around
the birthroot flower and he says he's
not they explain its significance how
whenever the three moons were created
the maiden was covered in a blanket of
birth roots and it was a sign from the
triple goddess that their world could
sustain life over the centuries the
flowers died off and they haven't been
seen for thousands of years they
interpret this as a holy sign three
elements made out of one and he says
just like my brothers and i to which
they respond just like the triple
goddesses at the end they're convinced
that he's clearly not a soul mired in
stagnation and anyone who says that will
be guilty of sin themselves from this
day forward no other zephyr will stand
in the way of the genetic dynasty so
essentially he's one everyone bows even
halima later on the way back to his ship
he thanks her for inspiring him to
attempt a spiral and then demarzel goes
to see her in her room she starts by
saying that she wants to extend her
condolences and then they have a
conversation where she admits that she
can't go against the emperor she can't
leave her role at his side and then
explains it was 11 000 years ago when
she walked the spiral which is basically
her admitting that she's a robot halima
had heard these rumors i guess they're
out there in the empire that the last
humana form robot in the galaxy does
assist the dynasty and demerizel
explains that like empire she doesn't
have individuated sentience she must not
be in possession of a soul either
because if she were she would be able to
disobey his commands and it's clear at
this point that she was sent there to
kill her we see that she's visibly
struggling and halima picks up on this
saying that she sees genuine remorse she
doesn't know how she can tell but she
knows that demarzel has a soul on the
other hand the person that's making her
do these things is truly a soulless man
she forgives her and tells her to do
what she must after all she's going to
be reincarnated according to her faith
she's already been poisoned through a
secretion when their skin touched and
after assuring her that she'll feel no
pain demerizel leaves she goes back and
tells cleon and assures him that it'll
look like she died of natural causes
then she asks him if he saw the ancient
birthroot flower on her desk which is
basically an accusation she's throwing
it out there that she wonders if he made
his vision up she explains that when she
did it she had a real vision and that
she would not wish that emptiness of
seeing nothing on anyone and it really
is an intense showdown between these two
characters as the spacers are preparing
him for the jump we get confirmation
that he didn't have a vision at all that
he was just there and what demarzel
implied was true which is a pretty big
revelation and i will come back to this
at the end
from there we go back to the raven and
we hear harry ask gail how long she's
been able to feel the future it's been
happening as long as she can remember
and most of the time it's just a feeling
like what happened with the micro meteor
but other times it comes in dreams harry
says that a dream drove her to
mathematics and that proves that it
wasn't a dream at all but a premonition
he thinks she might have some intuitive
processing ability that would put her
ahead of the math because that would
explain how she was able to solve
abraxas she wants to know why they're
going to helicon and he still thinks he
needs to keep her in the dark because
this prescience of hers has the
potential to skew psycho history
completely after all look what happened
with rach she's there and he's not and
this creates a big problem between them
the most hill giver is that mankind's
survival is predicated on us reaching
helicon and when she pushes saying that
she thought it depended on the
foundation he explains that it does to
an extent but only if its sister
organization is established as well so
there is a second foundation that needs
to be created at star's end on helicon
terminus was created by an imperial
charter and was designed in part to draw
fire but the second foundation and its
location must be kept secret even from
the first and things escalate from there
because she continues to ask questions
and he refuses to answer other than
saying that he has allies and resources
on helicon where they could safely study
her gifts and possibly use them to their
advantage she says that her instincts
are telling her to leave the same way
that she came and he points out the fact
that it would take her decades to get
determinus she wouldn't even be able to
go to trantor and that her best bet is
to stay on the raven it all boils down
to her giving harry an ultimatum tell
her everything or she'll destroy the
heat transfer system which will cause
her to die if she stays on the ship he
says he can't possibly do that he can't
jeopardize the second foundation before
it even gets started and when she
follows through when she destroys the
system he has the choice of either
letting her die on the ship or letting
her leave eventually he does and we see
her walk through the door she takes the
knife out of the lock and gets back into
the cryopod and when she asks the
navigation how long it'll take to get to
synax we find out that it's 138 years as
she confirms the destination so she's
going back to sleep headed towards a
dead planet as far as we know at that
point and that should effectively put
her out of the story for over a century
as i mentioned at the beginning it is
good to get some reveals people who'd
read the books knew that there was going
to be a reveal at some point about a
second foundation but even having that
idea going into it gail leaving here is
a pretty big twist i won't get into the
spoilers of why that is because we don't
really know what's gonna happen in the
next two episodes but what's important
here is that there's a second foundation
who are kept secret to help guide things
and it was always part of harry's plan
and i hope we learn a lot more about it
in the upcoming episodes another place
where i don't really know what's going
on is with the invictus i'm not sure how
much of what happened on the ship is
going to be important down the road the
idea of this ship's captain killing
herself will that turn out to be tied
into things elsewhere in the story i'm
not really sure they're seeing the word
exo and it meaning from outside the
galaxy probably was intentional but not
sure what to make of that at this point
the one place where we got resolution
was in the conflict between halima and
brother day although it does raise some
questions of its own it's pretty
fascinating that the whole point of this
journey is transformation i mean the guy
with faith happily laid down to die at
the end of his great effort because
there was no vision it's hard to say
which way he'll go as a result killing
off lima doesn't seem like a step in the
direction of becoming a more benevolent
ruler quite the opposite if you think
about it he deceived the whole religion
and then killed someone who wasn't even
really a threat anymore out of spite and
he used demarzel to do it and that's
probably more interesting was this bit
of implied cruelty that was enough to
get a bit of a reaction from her one of
the things that the showrunner mentioned
in the podcast was that each of these
clions they're basically the same but
they all go through different phases
where they try to individuate themselves
from their brothers and he mentioned
that as children they look at demarzel
as a mother figure then when they become
day they all sort of go through this
process of rebelling against her only to
then later like we saw with dusk right
before he became brother darkness they
fall back in love with her again so
there's a lot of stuff going on there
where they could go in different
directions i have a lot of ideas based
on the books which i won't mention but
it's still pretty hard to say
considering we don't really know much
about demarzel still at this point why
did she go walk the spiral 11 000 years
ago what was going on then 400 years ago
how did she come into service of cleon
the first there's a lot of really strict
rules that apply to robots in asimov's
works and at least where we're at right
now it seems she may be altered in a way
that makes her very hard to understand
there was really no reason for her to
lie to halima right before she killed
her she knew she was going to be dead so
i think everything that she said there
is our best information about what's
going on she doesn't have individuated
sentience and i'm really curious to see
what that means to her specifically in
relation to the dynasty and i think
that's a good place to leave things i'll
probably do another video this week to
try to suss some of these things out
there's a lot to think about and a lot
to discuss so let's pick it up in the
comments let me know what you're
thinking and if you want to talk book
spoilers just be sure to mark those
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon